Welcome to AV testing podcast your modern testing podcast your hosts Alan and Brent not here
We'll be here to guide you through topics on testing leadership agile and anything else that comes to mind now on with the show
Hey everyone, it's Alan here Brent is once again. He got called back to do some work for Satya
I think he is lubing the chassis on Satya's AI powered car. So we're gonna see how that goes
He'll be back shortly, but I am joined
I'm super excited today. I have a guest today. I have
Just a super interesting person. We've been talking we could have talked before I even press record like for an hour
But I thought I'd get a podcast done, too
He happens to be the CEO of CEO of sauce labs, but also a great mind in testing
Welcome Prince Coley Prince. Say hi to the say hi to everyone and tell us a little bit about yourself and why you're here
Hail and hi to everyone
I'm here because I love testing. I don't know that's so I you know, as Alan said in the sea of sauce labs
I have now been the technology industry
For I don't know like God knows 35 years or so
Undergrad computer science and PhD computer science use and I
wrote about
Persistent memory models, you know that's required for distributed systems before distribute systems are you know hot
so I love software and then been in the Bay Area Silicon Valley for
30 plus years
Technology companies as yeah, then my own company Tarros and Citrix for a long time platform engineering
Then Ericsson, you know had a huge team
Across the board really interesting because Ericsson is one of those people you don't really think about
But they have the world's data like they are literally every country of the world running the network
of cellular phones and data is king, you know as we know it as we all know
then
build agentic automation
Platforms at automation anywhere and then sauce labs, you know
I would love to get into why sauce labs at some point because I feel that the
You know the opportunity presented by the new kind of you know, AI world and testing is just amazing
So hence sauce labs, but here I am. Yeah here you are
And one thing that's been a common thread over the last
I don't know how many episodes of this podcast is how AI is affecting testing and you know, there's this if you're on LinkedIn
There's this it's just weird some people
Think AI is going to solve everything and he was what we needed
That's the right answer and some people think AI it doesn't work well at all
You should just ignore it also a horrible idea and I'm glad we have people like you who realize there are
Wonderful answers somewhere in the middle
So just we'll just start with this. So what what's your take? I know you live in the middle somewhere
What is AI doing to testing very wide open question. We get started with that very very very wide open question. Yeah
You know, I you can you know
The interesting thing here is you can you can stake any ground and probably have a few
You know ways to to to prove that ground is correct, but let me at least from my experience
So I have been in the software space now as an engineer then as a manager then as an exec
for a very long time, so I
I've run obviously, you know keyword teams like many of us many of you have
so to me
So testing has always been one of those things in software development that are critical that are key
but
But then here, you know, I might go out on the limb. Most people don't enjoy it, right?
It has been mechanical. It is hard to do. Honestly, I often say and I think I
Find most smart people nodding testing is harder than code writing
I've been saying that for 20 years. Yes, I know but you know, I
Think all smart people understand and I'm probably insulting a few but you know if you don't but I think testing is harder because you
Have to understand so much more about the environment you are in right?
There are edges there are there and why when you write code most people think of the happy path, right?
This is what it is supposed to do
But testing is all about the happy and the very unhappy parts and also the environment change all the time
And plus also code is written for environment one today and tomorrow the environment changes small changes
OS upgrades browser changes
but sometimes even more and
Testing is supposed to account for all of that. Right? How do you do that? It's impossible, right?
How do you write tests that are not themselves, you know that themselves don't run into regressions. It's a very hard
You know you you I mean you laugh knowingly. I know that right it reminds me of a conversation
I had probably 25 years ago is working on on
The user-level graphics GDI on early version of Windows
Yeah, and we had I remember having a long whiteboard conversation
There was a function called get pixel and set pixel to set the color of a pixel in the window
Yeah, the question was you know, the oracle question. Can we use get pixel to test set pixel?
Like oh, maybe we need to write code to go analyze the memory in the video buffer and see what's an it's like
No, it's yes. You can yes. The answer is yes
but but we
Try to make things hard and also if the pixels the wrong color someone's gonna notice. That's we don't need that
we don't need to go while but it's it's easy to go because in
When you're focusing on testing as this big world of things you can do and what I think is
The essence of testing is to figure out which are the tests you should do
Yeah
You know, I I'm so glad you bring that up people get lost in the universe
Right saying it's impossible. There are too many things and therefore I will do what I can and that is you know
I think the wrong approach
What is what is?
And the way sometimes that I put it here as well is you have to understand business intent and business focus
Right intent means what is the application supposed to do and second focus is what does it care about?
What do you care about right? Which are the parts that matter, right?
You don't really have to test for you know, some things don't really matter
They are too improbable and if you have a way to account for that outside that is okay
but
But the intent matters, right and the intent is outside the code
When someone says writes a spec for an application
You almost want to write a test driven spec
I want to say this is how the application should behave and that is a test driven spec and when the
You know when an input is not of the right type or the environment is not of the right type
Then it should behave like this that is also an intent driven spec and then whatever the code is that is written
The way to that at least I think about testing is that it should not at all look at the code
Especially kind of you know black box testing shouldn't look at the code at all
It should based on the intent of the test it should say this is what the application should behave like it should then
you know
It should exercise the application. It should
Create the right test cases which are independent of frameworks independent of you know
Shouldn't really care whether it's playwright or selenium and so on whatever the framework is of choice
Should be browser independent browser agnostic OS agnostic
Once you do that and you can write tests that are stable meaning your application goes from version 8.9 to 9.2
If the semantics have not changed the test should not break and that is such a big statement because today, right?
What happens is tests break because they are too sensitive to
Button placements or you know or form form field placement or you know my forever. Yes
Yeah, yeah, and you know you're just chasing your own tail at that point
You're just wasting your time in most of the time is spent fixing tests that should not have broken to begin with
So as long as and that kind of jumping back to your question
How does AI help?
What we have been able to do and I'm sure we are not the only ones is you use AI to glean intent
To get intent of the application out and there are multiple ways to do that
Then you author tests that test for that intent and make sure the intent is, you know, correctly verified
And then you do it at scale you do it with high quality high confidence
You do it with the right level of human governance, right?
And you do it with stability meaning you don't break if you do that, you know, it's golden, right?
Developers are 90% faster in writing tests AI code as you know at the last spec the last stat I saw
Was at 40% of code is now being generated and I'm sure I'm sure I'm sure that's rising quickly in some places much much higher
100% so we're seeing
development increase mass
exponentially if not more
The AI tools and I've used some of the AI tools to write code and I've used them two years ago as well
They're they've improved massively so developers are faster writing codes never been the hard part, but now it's even easier
Also, so I'll talk about from your angle is I've always been a believer that
The vast majority of testing should belong to the developer. They don't all functional correctness probably some more and and then
Some test expertise depending on the product is essential for understanding a lot of times fit a lot of times
Understanding if it's solving the customer problem in an intuitive way, which can't be done through automation
But it can be done through AI assistance to help you find the right things to do without leading you too much
Which I've already done. I'd love to hear your take on how
developers should be leveraging AI for a better functional correctness and then how
test specialists can use AI to
To help do I'll just say do their testing to help make sure the product has better customer fit
I'm keeping in mind under the umbrella. Is that my questions are way too long
The complaints that Brent and I saw we're talking about modern testing principles in a bit
We we made those because we were testers having a hard time navigating this world of agile delivered. Everything's moving faster
Now everything's moving even faster. So we're talking about what does AI mean for those test roles?
It doesn't mean you're out of a job
I don't think you can disagree with me, but how do we leverage AI?
both in developer testing and in
expert testing to keep up with the massive increase in
Developer productivity with AI tools. Yeah. Yeah, I think you're hitting
I think you're probably hitting most of the
Questions that people have in mind nowadays, you know in software development world a lot of people are saying
Software development world the largest software development world
so the way I think about testing is
It's an it's an it's an umbrella term right we sometimes you know, we call it release assurance, right? It's an umbrella term
it starts by
Understanding the what the application intent is then transferring that to authoring meaning create the right tests
Then execution run the tests on the right
Devices whether it's browsers or Android or iPhone or you know, whatever else it may be
then understand be able to
Look at the result and understand what happened
Did the tests pass?
If they failed I was it, you know, was it
some false positive when I was at a false negative
and
And also in case when they when they do fail what went wrong and how quickly can you get to the root cause?
Right how quickly can use that and by the way AI is very helpful in all of these. Yeah
And then after that be able to you know for any large-scale application rollout
You're going to have a be testing you're going to have beta
Rollout be able to understand that when users use the application
Does it match your expectation your tests are written for a certain?
Based on certain assumptions of usage
During beta and then during production be able to match that expectation of usage in the real world
with the tests that you have so all these things have to then come together and creates kind of this virtuous loop, right and
That is not a human solvable problem. It has to be done with AI humans are there on top orchestrating
You know understanding but AI has to be able to pull in this large pipes of data
Look what look for the right patterns look for understanding do a lot of the heavy lifting of creating the right tests
And then the biggest thing is tools like cursor are not creating code at breakneck speed
Testing was always a bottleneck
You don't want to suddenly turn around and realize you can do code at lightning speed and testing is actually become much worse
So now you have to start
Creating very high quality tests at at least the level of good creation
So that weakness in testing that always existed it is now, you know kind of
You know that it is the search light is now
Exactly and that's exactly the point I like to bring up with a lot of folks who are worried about you know AI taking their
jobs
There's always been holes in testing and I'm a big believer in theory of constraints
You know, it's one of our modern testing principles is you and the code parts really fast and
Testing was already in a lot of teams a bottleneck. Yeah, and it just highlights it more now. It's a bigger bottleneck
You can and I see some folks post on LinkedIn again
I make fun of LinkedIn, but they but they they want more time to test and
That's great for wanting that and it's great that you can do that and justify it saying I'm doing it for the customer
What's the use of developing code?
quality code and it's the code generated by code generation tools is
Identical or better than most human development
It's just not an option to say we're gonna slow down for testing. So how do we take this thing? That's been slow already and
Fragile and the story I thought of when you're talking a minute ago was at a time I was at Microsoft
There were 10,000 testers at Microsoft and I would bet every this is probably true
I would say based on my information it is true because I saw it on a large division
I would guess every one of those testers spent a chunk an hour or two of everyday
Debugging failed tests to see if they're really a product issue hundred percent do that math and count the money and now
Now I don't care how expensive tokens are it's cheaper now
And it's more fun work, so
talk a little bit more about how like AI shining that light on testing and how
Like the AI code generation is and how we can use AI to
Accelerate that testing process. Yep. Yep. So so
You know right writing so starting at the very top right writing writing the right tests
You know, that's very hard. And if you are if you can use AI
To
Take let's say a PM written spec and RFEs or just take a figma design
And say I'm going to then use a design in the behavior
Which is implicit or explicit in the design or in the spec and then
Translate that to a test on any in any given framework of choice
That's just just that is saving you days, you know easily days per person. I would go less technical
How about we talk about here is because my favorite quotes is customers don't want software with their problem solved
What if I just said I have some software that's supposed to solve this problem
What test do I need to run to make sure that problem solved? Yeah, see, but that's
That's and you know, I think that's as simple as it gets right? Yeah, it is it is if you want to it wouldn't get
everything but
One thing I've talked about. I'm sorry. Keep on it. I was gonna let you talk keep on interrupting
I get excited about this stuff. I think
The ability to judge and discern the answers you get from a
Generative AI solution you're trying to trying to guide some
Pick your tool there's some questions and refinement of questions the ability to do that
Well leads to massively good results
The inability to do that well leads to a lot of the complaints folks have about AI generated test cases
Yeah, that's 100% correct and that and by the way that is also now, you know going from an art to a science, right?
Which is what do you feed right? What kind of you know, people call it prompt engineering, but it's far more than that now
Yeah, I hate her. Yeah
It trivializes
Something so important right the context you provide it and the data you provide around the context and
Then your own expertise that you provide that you know, that is what makes a tool work better. The tool is not magic, right?
I mean it you need to get the right results. So then authoring a huge deal
It is one of the things that developers see developers should be testers function, especially functional testers
There should be that and and developers. I mean we have already developers in the past
We don't like writing tests
We would we want to we want tests writing to be as easy quote-unquote as easy as software writing
And with AI it is yes
It never was that much harder
Especially now especially now that's right and that with AI
I think that is one of the core of core solutions that are presenting themselves that with AI you can now
Create tests at the speed that you are writing code and you can create excellent tests far better than you could actually code yourself
Earlier just you know, that is just an in just the truth
And these are stable tests. You don't have to keep on
I mean, like you said 20% 30% of the time at least is being spent in fixing old tests
All that goes away because if you because I mean
Ecommerce application, right? There is a cut there's the shopping cart
I can put a t-shirt in it and I should be able to you know
Delete add add things to the cart and delete things from the cart
the semantics of the shopping cart do not change just because you upgrade it from one release to the other and
Earlier tests would fail even though the semantics
One one changing so as long as the semantics have a change your tests are stable
You can regenerate the tests but the tests are stable and that is a huge thing that AI is able to
You know he is able to bring forth and then of course, sorry good
Yeah, so over there so, you know from a from a test expert perspective and I you know
I'm not going to put a hat on whether it's just a tester or a developer, you know
Because roles are hybrid nowadays anyway, so from a test expert quality expert perspective
Test coverage
understanding what the test does test coverage
Therefore application coverage
Then the ability to keep test stable running at scale and get information back on what is failing
Why is it failing?
Those are things that testers did spend their entire days doing and then of course the other part which is in production and things
Are running how do you get that data understand that data and make sure that your tests are?
Speaking to the real world right because the real world is not going to speak to your tests
yeah, all that and I'm gonna bring in the the modern testing principles again a little bit because
We've gotten a push back and flack on some of those for a long time. It's fine. It's fine
They weren't meant to be controversial
I don't know why they are to some people but all the things that were difficult there now get easier today as well
the one I
Forget the worry. I'm not gonna look them up right now, but we have I've actually I will
We had one around data. We thought the one that said that
We expand abilities know how across the team understanding this may reduce or eliminate that even dedicated specialists
Was the one that would cause problems people said nope, that's fine
We get that the one that people get mad about is
we said we believe that the customer is the only one capable to judge and evaluate the quality of the product and
the
Reaction on that is well, you're asking customers to test. No, no
They're not gonna enter bug reports aren't giving them a test case
But we want to understand is through data another principle
is the is the software solving the problem expected to do our customers hitting error paths and
This comes back to the asking the right prompts if I'm a developer
Not only am I asking how am I what are the right tests for me to create?
I'm gonna ask questions a good developer should ask questions around
How will I know the software is behaving in production and say all you need to measure this and this and this and it'll help
You the difficult part was figuring out. Okay, what how do I add telemetry? What where do we collect it? What does it do?
There's just a lot of it makes every developer
Who knows how to use it and knows the right questions to ask and there's a lot of education
We can give our teams on that but you can get a lot of
Value from asking the right question
So then the point is getting the code in to generate the data that tracks how customers not there
No, PII, but what paths are they using?
What failures are they seeing that's?
infinitely easier now and then we can write tests based on that we can write production assertions based on that all of a
Sudden we know all all this stuff what's going on and we can monitor it
We have a whole new insight into how customers are using our software
You know to build on that right so I completely agree to build on that in the modern world right SAS world
The role of it's not just a tester
But the product managers are able to then tell how a product is being used how to prove it and and also they could
Ask those questions too. They could they could vibe code in the telemetry there. There you go. There you go
And I think people sometimes
Do not exploit the power the data provides them right especially in the SAS world where all the data if you if you have
the right telemetry
You know the code paths, you know the hotspots, you know, where people spend time, you know where they don't go at all
that allows you to test better create better applications and then
Earlier the data was not the insights were not accessible
I think you know, I mean how much data dog and Splunk can you do right?
But they were not accessible and now they have suddenly become accessible in natural language in
A
Conversational format and pattern match AI is so good at pattern matching. That's right
It reminds me of a conversation I had in a cafeteria again all these things that were really really hard
Earlier in my career. It's like the the lights are on bright
I had someone come up to me working on exchange the the back-end server for Microsoft
And I said I get
Two terabytes of telemetry every day and trying to find insights like needle in a haystack for a human
impossible, but
So much easier with with with
You write an agent to go find the top five issues customers were seeing that day
Which is which is exactly what we do, you know and our customers, you know
This I won't give you a product pitch, but I'll give you a pitch about the about the area
when we
Start selling these products that we have in this release assurance and you know many of the things we just talked about
It's one of those rare moments where every customer every prospect you go to and you say this is what we can do
They all say
all you want to all I want to know is if it works as you say because if it does I'm going to
Buy it because everyone has a problem, right?
Everyone is worried about the amount of code that is being created the quality of that code that is being created
the slowness of testing and and and the
And the effort to push code out without truly verifying it and truly even knowing who wants you know
The quality of that code if you're able to solve it with AI native
Other AI native code like we have then it makes everyone's life easier. Yeah, I'm I
had a thought and
AI and people aren't here yet, but I have some thoughts around how AI is changing our software is delivered and
hinted at some of the four
the challenges that
Didn't have higher ROI before like, you know, let me write something to analyze these two terabytes of data
That too much work or the little utility that makes my life a little easier. Yeah, it's fine
It's not the ROI that ROI bar has changed so much if there's something that it may take
5,000 lines of code
But it's salt but it saves me 30 minutes every day. I would I would 10 years ago
I would never go write that now I can have an AI write that in
Five minutes I could test it and my so much time is saved and then here's the question for you
So that's just me as a developer
marketing legal sales
Accounting they can all also create software solutions to make their lives a little bit easier
They're not always going to put to a production, but they may be hosted in AWS somewhere
They may be doing things they may have to test their stuff. So can be used across the whole department
How can AI I mean?
I'm gonna get back to where AI is going with testing
But we have a whole bunch of people who were never creating code before who can now create code and if they aren't now
They will be in the next few years
What?
Then then what happens?
Yeah, I mean we actually have a real-world example. I can't name the customer for obvious reasons
But one of one of the largest banks in the world
Their market we were demoing it to the CTO team, right?
You know, that's where most R&D lives their marketing department came to us and they said their marketers want to use this
Because now they can actually test the thing that is going out and and they were just so excited to be able to do that
And that is just a to me. That is just a start of a completely new journey
Yes, and that's what I'm really excited about that
So if that's it so now we're saying not only I mean some testers freak out
We can say developers can do testing and say no they can't and now we're saying we're going farther
We're saying no marketing can do development testing
These poor people are gonna have to hold on to their hats. So all that said
Two part question easy one first. What is AI doing the test?
It's all that says it's AI taking testing jobs away and after you answer that
How is AI changing what software testers do today? So on the first one
You know, I I think there is always this worry that tools take jobs away
I find tools make jobs
take the mechanical part of job away and allows people to
Use the brain, you know brain cells
They have to do actually things that are far more insightful and interesting and it makes the quality of your job better
Then you like going to work more than you used to earlier. So I don't think jobs go away
It is I mean, it's like, you know, you go back 40 years
Compilers were created right developers suddenly didn't lose their jobs, right? They just wrote more code. Yeah, right
It's exactly the same thing. I don't think it's all it's the same story different different actors different subject
That's right things become easier and therefore more things get done. It doesn't mean less things get done
So that I don't worry about I think the job that role will evolve as it has been evolving now for 40 years
So that part is okay
The rule does change though, right it does change because you know last 25 years at rent has been that manual testing
Is just not the right way to do things you can start with manual, but you really have to go to you know
auto automated testing
the level of automation and the level of
Automated automation almost, you know with the new LLM based testing solutions
That is something the testers have to be able to exploit now
So that in that sense the role has changed just a developer role has changed
Developers who don't know how to use codecs or cursor or you know, Gemini based tools
And if they don't know how to do that, I think they will be forced to learn
similarly in the testing world people who won't care about quality we have to learn how to
exploit
You know these tools and and make sure that the code that they are writing is then testable in the right way
And but but I see that again I see that as a wonderful new ways of doing things not as a not as a worry area
Yeah, so one thing and this is the same thing happen with agile as well. Yeah, and in that transition
I saw a lot of folks and again, I keep on dropping
Janet Gregory and this Christmas book on agile testing. That's the first one I read where I'd not in my head so hard
I think it's chapter five talks about managers said the manager's job turns into a coach
and
Taken one step further. I think a lot of and we've seen this happen a lot in the industry
Especially over the last couple of years, but even before you end up with the really good tester being the coach
traditionally pre AI
Helping developers understand what tests are right or pairing with them on tests or or bringing some of that testing expertise into the team
That's what I meant by that principle number seven
That coach now is I see it. I'm curious on your thoughts here. I see that coach moving from
What sort of questions do we ask the AI to make sure this code is higher quality and that I mean they can coach
The marketer as much as the developer. Mm-hmm. Yeah
You know, it's actually I think a deeper question than most most people realize
see if
You know, it's such a good question
How do you how do you know a code is high quality and how do you ask it to be certain that it is?
High-quality that means you must truly understand the intent of the code. You must truly be able to say
You you know
My code entity you are supposed to be doing X Y and Z when you see input a B and C
You should be doing X Y and Z and the ability to enumerate enumerate those
and the ability to think of all of those inputs is
What determines quality in many ways
If you can if you can describe the surface area of the application and also of the environment as fully as possible
Then you know your quality bar is set to the right level at least in my view
Yeah, and I'll give you an example here in a second
I think you're right, but the difference is now that's always been the question
We've had to answer for quality. Yeah. Now we just are answering it a thousand times more often than we used to
So let's look at we're using
This is not a plug, but I've been very happy with a product called a riverside to record podcasts. Let's be do some fun things
It records locally does all the stuff. It's supposed to
Let's say riverside was created with AI in a day. They've obviously I'm not picking on you riverside
What questions do we ask? It's just it's basically still people having use riverside
It's basically an audio video client with some bells and whistles. So there's a lot of intent here. How do we use AI?
Like what sort of questions do you ask like what's like I just on the spot here
How do we know if riverside all that stuff? I've said it has screwed up a little before
How do we know if riverside is good quality? There you go. See we are doing why you're doing my QA right now on
And I don't have a good answer. I'm just kind of curious. We're gonna riff on this for a minute move on
How do you know like yeah, it's always the hard question
How do you like as if I go the only the customer knows really the customer is they're the one it solves my problem
because customers want their problem solved it solves my problem, which I need a good way reliable way to record podcasts, but
We don't just want to throw it to the customer first and see if they they cancel their subscription or not
So how what can we do to make sure it's?
High enough quality that the customer can give us their evaluation. Yeah
Can I love some ideas? Yeah, so so, you know, I would the way I would think about this is that
See riverside is interesting because it is an
Existing application right in in many ways that
Makes some parts easier and I say that carefully
Because the way the part that makes it
the easier part is I
Would ask a I said to say go look at the riverside recordings and look at the comments from users and use all that data
And say what does it do just before I do anything?
Yeah, what does it do go pull from reddit or they have a Facebook community wherever they have community pull from there
Yeah, go you know good go look at all that and educate yourself
You know become an expert or what it is supposed to do or train the AI to be expert on it
Yeah
Then when you know that then go and make sure that you have written
You know a set of rules and and and ways to test it and say make sure you exercise the application
In these ways to verify that what it is supposed to do
It does that's where I would start and then you know, of course, I would build on that
But that's a way for an existing application because you know, I think you said this multiple times earlier
It's a customer who determines a truth. Yeah, if the customer uses in a certain way, then there you go
You have gold already
Yeah, and I wonder if talk about intense and I think you're you're right there and we're just riffing here
What if I just made Riverside never heard of before an application and as part of the onboarding side that people hate a bunch
Of questions. Yeah, what if there's one question or like what what problem do you hope like what are you?
What do you want to accomplish with Riverside or?
What if you're switching if you're switching for another platform, what's the biggest reason why I wouldn't ask a lot?
Because people won't fill it out
But if you get a lot of users and they just give you some little one-sentence answers
Then all of a sudden you're capturing customer intent that you can keep and then use in that same way
That's then they have the reactive one going to look at forums
So there's yeah
These are these are ways of thinking about quality that I don't think many testers or any software development teams have thought about
much before
Yep, you know and and it's almost a crowd-sourced, you know intent creation, right?
And then and then you can add lawyers in the middle you can say by the way lawyers in lawyers or support engineers
Let's not even go to legal support engineers. No CSMs right customers
You know, they know how the customers use a product how they expect to be using a product
Suddenly they become your testers because a CSM engineer a support engineer can then go in and and wipe code right or create
you know, I don't
Code but in a healthy way these test scripts and say my this product we are shipping
exchange Microsoft exchange server
It must do these things because that's how my customer uses it then suddenly that is a script that is stable
That is a script that is going to be done every time, you know pre shipment, right?
overnight sanity tests, so the richness of
The quality tests that you have is going to increase and it's going to reflect the real world
Not just one person's point of view. Yeah, I think
I'm just thinking out loud here. I think things like the give feedback
button yeah
Become much more valuable because something's not working
I get a chance to like just type something in and send it off
Yeah, all of a sudden that becomes a rich set of data
I can use to see like what isn't working for folks and I and in that we can capture
You know browser information or whatever get some information like oh, this is how we find out that
I
Get this is where soft tools like sauce helps test on a bunch of different browsers
But this is where I find out. Oh, we don't render on opera. That's right something
Yeah, and then automatically right?
You know if you use something like sauce you automatically take this data and you create
New tests because if there is a hole that got because if something got shipped right and it was broken clear click
There's clearly a hole somewhere, right?
So you take that you're not just right the test
But you also make sure the test is run all the time and that way you just get better every time and you don't regress
So the new world, you know with this, you know, everything in the CI CD pipeline everything connected to each other
It's it's been used well, I think this will raise the you know, there is there is the
Bar for everyone. Yeah, and I think I hinted this before I think if your
software delivery process was really good before
If you were doing CD or before it be sort of using AI
Your transition to AI was probably pretty easy because you had confidence that anything you checked in or a human checked in could go
to production
If you didn't you're struggling because it's not that AI is the problem. The problem is you never addressed your bottlenecks
and
I was talking to a company a few a while back time is weird
and they
We're happy with AI
Generating a vast majority of their code, but they still wanted a human to code review every code change. Hmm. It's a bottleneck
Hmm. So then how do you choose which ones to review and what do you do and there and then again?
You can AI to help solve those problems
You can shove a human in where you need to but any time you're putting a human into the system
You're adding an intentional bottleneck. Yep, and that may be okay depending on the software the context all kinds of reasons, but
If that's the issue the problem is not AI generating code. The problem is you don't have a way to
Again, there's
Sometimes the human is needed
But you want to minimize that so that you never have a human bottleneck or if especially it's traditionally
There would be the one human who go on vacation that nothing could really that's like the story of the Phoenix project
Poor poor Brent in the Phoenix project couldn't go on vacation
He was the bottleneck on everything. Yeah
yeah, it's a
See the the the nature
See the niche in the CD right in CI CD pipelines
If you hadn't deployed well, and if you were already in some of these modern modern SDLC in modern testing
Then developers then testing was not a burden of one team or one person
right testing was already spread over multiple users and they knew what the code was doing and
The developers already owned a chunk of it
Then your life is easier now anyway, because then the transition to AI is very natural
yeah, now if you were in the liberal the older world where
Testing was all downstream, right?
There was a team that tested at the very end then you are in trouble and that is only exposing a problem that you
Always had I mean it is not a exactly exactly what I'm seeing is that was already a problem for you now
It's just much more obvious the same thing if even if you couldn't do CD to a lesser extent
It's
The problem was always there the accelerant of code generation is us highlighting problems elsewhere in the system
And that's true in any system
If you speed up one part, it'll highlight where the slower parts are elsewhere
That's correct. And that's what the goal the theory of constraints the goal of Phoenix project are all about
so if you're a team if you're a
I'll just say a team when you say a test team if you are a team delivering software and you're
Struggling with the speed to ship as fast as you want with the speed of AI ship confidently
What are
What advice would you give that team? I won't give it a limit
I give me a couple pieces of advice you give a team who are
Struggling to keep up with the speed of AI generated software
Like a CEO says like we're writing code all the time
Shipping it and they say because blah blah blah. Like what advice do you give that team? You know, it's very simple. I
to us
to me
AI native code generation is accelerating code creation and that is actually a good thing, right?
because when it started there was a lot of AI slop and that slope will decrease over time the quality of the code is
Getting the the translation from intent to code quality is getting better
In the same way
verification has to proceed independently and use AI and be a native in that sense to make sure that code as written is
Towards the intent of the code you have no choice
I mean you cannot you cannot skip your way past it
You cannot trust your code and say everything will be fine because a I wrote it that's kind of would not be very smart at
all
You almost always also want to use a different LLM
By the way, if you use one LLM for code writing, I would suggest you
Right. I mean you just you know, I you don't want to trust everything to Peter you want to have Bob in there as well
So so so that's the way I would do it. I would say start, you know start with
You know with the platform or a set of tools that
Again, like I described earlier are able to more or less autonom on autonomously
Understand the internet of the application write the tests for it be able to execute the tests on the right platforms devices
Whatever the need is and
As you go forward are able to look at the results of the test and automatically because you really want to address the entire cycle
Automatically tell you where things may be going wrong and think of a release manager or a QA manager set, right?
They want to be quickly they want to be able to quickly tell what ran last night what broke
Where do I go look with that's our so work every day
And then of course take that forward into deployment into the beta into real-world deployment
and bring all that data back and make sure that your
your tests are addressing real-world user scenarios and that you're able to
Keep on accelerating the software development lifecycle not slow it down. Yeah. Yeah
so similar question
And maybe a little bit more direct that I'll open things up is if I'm a tester now on a team
And I am worried that I'm going to lose my job of AI
What do I do to make myself?
Like actually I won't even lead that what should I do? What should I do just?
If you haven't yet already
Go start playing with any LLM that you want. It doesn't matter which LLM, right?
There are many of them and for to start with all of them are good enough
start with that start into
wipe testing almost
Ask it to create any application that you have just give it a prompt saying I have you know
I the example I use earlier. I have a shopping cart application
whatever it may be a shopping at application or I have AWS I want to test AWS and
or other in Amazon retail and
Write me a set of tests on this framework that goes and and
Exercises this just play with it. See people I people already forgotten time has moved
So fast two years ago when people were going starting to write software with AI two twenty half years ago
It wasn't that long, right? I remember we're saying you remember people were saying oh this will never work
You know many people and then the first thing that people told others saying look don't don't worry
Just start with anything right just ask it to write a program and see what happens
And then before you know it suddenly it gets better and gets better and you start realizing how to make it write
programs
Testing is actually
Exactly analogous you have to go try a few things. It's really writing a program
Sometimes more sophisticated programs, but it does make life easier for you
That's the way I would start start learning those things and then and there are platforms out there like ours that provide you
Many of these things out of the box
Then you will to ask us better question saying how do you work? Yeah, you solve my problem one thing
I did I was working with some
Gen AI
Generated test automation and
There was a little bit of learning curve like how can I ask the I knew a bug was there
So and this is a fun way to do it learn to ask the questions that will make it find that bug
And and there's some discretion there. I think there is an art
I hate the term prompt engineering, but there is an art to figuring out
What questions to ask and how to interact with an LLM to give it the answer you're looking for?
It's a say actually and this is funny. It's the same with the Google search. This is why
Some people will say I'm having a hard time this is the oldest we'll use Google first
They say I haven't a hard time finding this that's what they're looking for and I'd ask I'd use slightly different
Search criteria that finance a firm right away. There's an art just as there is an art to a search query
There's a more nuanced art to LLMs and getting that and getting what you want out of them
So practice doing that figure out what they're good and bad at don't get all excited because it can't figure out if you should walk
Or drive to the car wash understand how they work so you could ask them
Questions that they can answer. Yeah
Yeah, yeah, I'm with you and people who have you know a programming past and so on will find that
It's exactly the same pattern when you start writing a program at first and you get frustrated because it doesn't do what you thought
It you told it to do you realize that you had to code it more carefully, right?
You know, yes exactly
And and a lot of times it leaves something else like oh I've learned to add
To ask this question, which is why I think
You know pair programming always a good idea
I think pair prompting is a great way to learn as well or even whether I know what you're doing pair prompting
I think is a fun idea
Imagine a developer paired with a marketer on trying to vibe code an app
Oh, wow, I think I think it could work because because the the marketer knows the problem
They want solved much better. Even if they explained it to the developer for an hour, they know it
They know the new ones. Oh, I can't do that because of a B and C. I always come back to the anthropic
Vibe coding contest to call it something different but a lawyer one
Because he knew the domain area around the problem
Solved really well any great this some verification now for some licenses. So it's
There's there's something there. Yeah, imagine what hackathons are going to look like now. Yes a whole company
I want to do a hackathon with a whole company. Yeah, yeah solve something cool and get some nice show-and-tell at the end
That's right. And you and you actually will create a real application at the end, right? Yeah. Yeah a real application
Great. So let's go ahead and wrap it up
Before that, is there any last the the meta question here? Is there anything I should have asked you that I didn't
so I you know, we got a lot of ground and I think I
Strongly suspected many of the questions you did ask a top of mind. I think for your audience as well for sure
the only thing I would add is
And this is most people may know it but I would say that
see most of our customers are very large companies large enterprises and
I just want to tell the audience here that
They are very smart about this already and many people are already using AI native AI native
Products such as such as sauce labs
To solve many of these problems
You would think large companies are going to be slow. That is not the case
Large companies are moving very fast the pressure on them to move fast is high
They feel the need to move fast
so my advice is
Learn learn quickly and
It actually is a lot of fun. It's actually if more fun than you would realize so so so spend some time on it
Sounds fantastic. Well, this has been an amazing conversation. I'm so happy you're you're here and it has talked about this stuff
I think this is very relevant everyone listening and I appreciate the time today. So thank you
Thanks, Ellen and thanks to everyone. Thank you know for listening. Alright, this has been I don't know what episode like 232
the AB testing podcast